Commander-in-Chief,
in accordance with the training plan for the
armed forces of the Russian Federation, under
your leadership, training is being conducted
to control the armed forces of the
Russian Federation, during which the
task of delivering a
massive nuclear strike by
strategic offensive forces in
response to an enemy nuclear strike will be worked out.
how every man is obliged to defend his
homeland I think, that is, this is not even
discussed, that is, all of my
men are military personnel in the company who
all received a summons, all profits, there
are also a lot of Volunteers, they
also served their years, but I already forgot that
I took a lot
there over  there are a lot of fees for
myself, unless someone
emphasized for themselves tactical
training military medical training
rotten training,
therefore, the most
time is the most necessary, so we work every
day without days off
well, without knowledge it won’t work, let’s say if
you are invited to try to cook
brown it won’t work the first time and I
think even from the second experience the son of difficult mistakes
Thanks to our commanders that they feed us like that,
but it happens